it is time to focus on mother's day we
are literally five days away from the
special celebration which is why we have
celebrity lifestyle expert sema cohen
joining us to share her ultimate
mother's day gift guide take a look
hello las vegas now and happy mother's
day
it doesn't matter what you call her mom
madre or mama
she's the backbone of the family and the
glue that holds it
all together this mother's day i'm
excited to bring you
my ultimate mother's day gift guide life
is busy and we all need an energy drink
that will keep
us all focused and driven throughout the
day rowdy energy offers precise
time-released caffeine and sugar
reduction
ingredients always an amazing taste
it offers a natural blend of caffeine
from green tea
and l-theanine to offset calf aim
jitters
rowdy offers five zero sugar flavors
and two reduced sugar options every
route is packed with a boost of
electrolytes
without any additives or artificial
ingredients
there are no artificial flavors all
colors
everything is naturally derived from
fruits
and vegetables rowdy is a smarter
cleaner better for you energy drink and
you can
you can find them at terrible herbs and
camping world
and you can also find them at
rowdyenergy.com
curryuma offers a sustainable sneakers
made from organic canvas leather and
sweat
cariuma works exclusively with ethical
factories
and sources only natural and recycled
materials
carrioma is working to restore the
brazilian rainforest
supporting the communities that live
there with the pair
for a pair program for all pairs sold
the money goes towards planting trees
and income
for the people of the region where one
pair of shoes
means planting one pair of trees
you can find them at cariuma.com
skin and co is a family beauty brand
creating
skincare products using botanical
extract from the farms
in italy where they grow the ingredients
and handcraft all of the products
they use mediterranean super
antioxidants
like black truffle sicilian orange and
sunflower from tuscany to boost the skin
with non-toxic ingredients you can find
them at skinanco.com
last but not least print fresh
print fresh is a collection of sleepwear
stationery and gift items and unique
whimsical prints that are hand screened
printed
made from 100 organic cotton print fresh
offers variety
of styles including long sets short sets
and ropes in all sizes up to
six eggs you can find at printfresh.com
wishing everyone a beautiful fantastic
happy mother's day this year
[Music]
thank you sema for all things lifestyle
you can follow her
on instagram at sema cohen official jay